[Music]
there is a u.s. territory it's fairly
obscure called Saipan it's a relic of
the Second World War but it has been
part of an American territory called the
Commonwealth of the Northern Mariana
Islands it is not so far from Guam which
is probably the nearest place that most
people have heard of administrative Lee
it's kind of similar to Puerto Rico and
it's had a kind of troubled economic
history never really finding an industry
that makes sense to keep its economy
going but a few years ago it entered an
agreement with a Chinese company to
construct a huge casino really massive a
kind of Macau sized development out
there in the middle of nowhere in the
Pacific and after that things got things
got pretty weird
[Music]
I'm Matthew Campbell I am a reporter for
Bloomberg Businessweek
I wrote a story called paradise bot all
about the investment of a Chinese casino
on the island of saipan actually what
had happened was a colleague of mine in
Asia who covers the casino business had
heard of this place because the company
that was operating this casino called
Imperial Pacific based in Hong Kong was
reporting its numbers to the Hong Kong
Stock Exchange and the numbers that were
being put up in Sipan were absolutely
astonishing in the billions per month at
a casino that was on this island truly
in the middle of nowhere the Imperial
Pacific is actually a little bit
mysterious in its origins we know that
it is controlled by a mother and son
from Harbin in northern China and they
are very wealthy certainly they seem to
have earned their money initially on the
mainland in a number of businesses
particularly real estate and then they
came to Macau where they got involved in
in what are called junkets which are
these mechanisms by which Chinese
nationals
gamble in Macau and and often as another
consequence of that are able to move
money out of the country so when Saipan
began looking to whether a casino could
be the answer to its economic problems
Imperial Pacific showed up and very
quickly won approval and a very generous
deal to construct this casino and to
then operate it without paying a great
deal in tax there was a big problem from
the beginning of Imperial Pacific's
project in Saipan which was that no one
had ever built anything this large there
this is an island of small buildings
it's kind of like a quiet American
suburb and here was this Chinese company
proposing to construct a Vegas or Macau
sized installation right in the middle
of the city center of Saipan largest
town
so they need workers and where did they
find those workers well it turned out
many of them and this was something that
was investigated by the US federal
government were tourists were Chinese
nationals who had entered on tourist
visas into Saipan and have been gone
straight to work at the construction
site I spoke to one person who had
worked as a site supervisor there in
charge of implementing safety rules who
said that it was the most difficult
project he'd ever worked on
because basic safety requirements were
not being followed and sure enough there
were a great deal of injuries there was
one death that was documented and things
actually got so bad that at the the
hospital in Saipan the doctors were
keeping a kind of unofficial spreadsheet
listing injuries from workers from the
site to keep track of how many patients
they were seeing who had been hurt while
working to build this casino so while I
was in Saipan I went and with the help
of a colleague translated to see some of
these construction workers who were
living in a sort of dormitory barracks
like structure not so far from the
casino they were angry they were
claiming they had not been paid that
they had been injured and not properly
treated and really just aggrieved in
every respect these workers were
employed by a series of contractors that
Imperial Pacific had hired to build its
casino pier old Pacific has said that it
is in full compliance with all of these
rules that any issues for example around
immigration and and illegal labor being
used on the construction site these
things are being done without its
knowledge they have also said that
safety violations again were either done
without their knowledge or that the site
is complied with all the relevant safety
rules
Imperial Pacific of course needed
someone to actually run this casino and
and I think it's fair to say it needed
an American face it needed someone who
could operate natively in an American
context and so it hired a guy called
Mark Brown who had cut his teeth
actually in the Trump Organization and
in Trump casinos so he was kind of in
the Trump orbit he's someone who has
described Trump as a mentor as someone
who is very influential in his career
that we are guests here you know we're
investing in the island to determine
culture that's here we're guests so
we're very honored and privileged to be
here and we will be here for many many
years to come
Brown was the person running it he was
the face of it appearing at meetings
doing interviews of the local papers
however he eventually left he then came
back and then I believe he left again
and he's now no longer with the company
[Music]
one of the things that got me interested
in this story was this astonishing list
of big name of Washington political
figures who Imperial Pacific had managed
to collect over the years as board
members in some cases advisors in other
cases you had David Patterson a former
governor of New York
ed Rendell former governor of
Pennsylvania you had Jim Woolsey who ran
the CIA Louis Freeh who ran the FBI one
of the things that really struck me as I
reached out to some of these people was
that they hadn't done much due diligence
Rendell for example told us that
essentially his assistant had googled
Imperial Pacific and done a bit of
online reading and he'd concluded from
that that this was an okay assignment
for him to take an okay check for him to
take it's probably safe to say they were
they were hired to provide a degree of
air cover that if you have people with
these big names on the payroll they can
help you stay away from from any
regulatory or legal problems pretty much
all of these figures eventually stepped
down from these roles but they were for
a long time associated with this company
that had really serious questions about
its operations and its activities and
its influence in this u.s. territory
as part of my reporting I came across a
guy called Mike Neto who is a maritime
consultant in Singapore who had been
hired to move one of Imperial Pacific's
yachts from Saipan back to Asia and he
was doing this normal assignment and
then the yacht encountered mechanical
trouble in Philippines so he slowed down
to see if he could get some help and was
then approached by the Philippine Coast
Guard
it appears that Imperial Pacific had
reported the vessel stolen and as a
result mike and the yacht were impounded
in a small city in the philippines and
he was stuck on board for a few days not
permitted to leave and while he was on
board he could see through surveillance
cameras as three men appeared and
started removing what appeared to be big
bricks of US cash from the yacht and I I
asked him repeatedly if he was sure
these were bricks of US cash and he said
they absolutely were he actually
reviewed the footage a few times to be
sure now it should be pointed out
Imperial Pacific has said this is not
true and that the yacht was attacked by
pirates obviously mr. Neto disagrees
with that so this was just another very
strange alarming thing that happened or
in the orbit of this casino
[Music]
from the beginning of the casino story
in Saipan which goes back to about 2013
there was a lot of support from the
current governor Ralph Torres who is
from one of sy pans big political
families there were interesting
questions about why the governor came to
support the casino when a casino was
initially being considered for Saipan he
was in the Senate he actually voted
against it then over time as I learned
and was able to to document through my
investigation there had emerged
significant financial links between the
governor's family and Imperial Pacific
his three brothers run a law firm
Imperial Pacific actually had that law
firm on the payroll and and paid it
quite a lot of money there had been land
deals with people who the governor was
related to to obtain long-term leases on
land around the island and just a
general sense that this company and misc
administration were incredibly close and
aligned in their interests Imperial
Pacific has said that they have complied
that they have not broken any rules and
that they are operating just as any
company in the United States should
governor Torres has said repeatedly and
including in a recent statement that he
has never benefited him properly from
the presence of the casino or from
Imperial Pacific that his brothers have
not benefited improperly that any land
deals have not resulted in funds flowing
to him I have a duty to do and to
continue what I am voted for and I just
without governor Torres without support
from his allies in the legislature I
think it's fair to say that Imperial
Pacific would not have been able to act
in the way that it has over the last
several years
this is a company that has repeatedly
failed to live up to the commitments
that it made in its initial agreement
with the government of Saipan which
stipulated it would construct a certain
number of hotel rooms by a certain date
that the casino would be up and running
that it would pay a certain amount of
tax overtime many of those commitments
have not been met and yet the islands
government and its regulatory body which
is called the Commonwealth Casino
Commission has just continued extending
it wrote continued allowing Imperial
Pacific to operate asking it to make
good on these promises but not really
enforcing anything and obviously the
license has not been cancelled located
in the heart of Saipan is the villas at
Imperial Palace in addition to the Seoul
Casino on Saipan the villas opened up
two months ago with six completed and
eight on the way currently the finished
villas arterial Pacific has become
really the most important force on this
island by a huge margin it was
dominating the economy it was dominating
politics it was building a structure
larger than anything the island had ever
seen and it was doing all of these
things in ways that had people there and
people in the industry and people on the
US mainland very concerned about
corruption about safety about crime and
about whether this island could become a
hub for money laundering or other
activities that it shouldn't be at 5:00
p.m. yesterday the Federal Bureau of
Investigation agents executed one of
their multiple search warrants and
opened the doors of Imperial Pacific
International cinemas main office this
comes after FBI agents raided cnmi
governor Ralph Torres's office vehicle
and home as well his brothers law firm
Torres brothers know
seeing my administration something is
happening in the criminal justice system
whether that leads to charges and if so
against whom and for what we still don't
know but this story has some way to run
[Music]
you
you